[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been a while since we last went
through a few tips and tricks to stay
ahead in fortnight battle royale well
let's put that right right now 35 tips
watching those pro players over on
Twitch last time I made one of these
videos I asked what your favorite skin
is so let's do it again
great skin in the game for me it has to
be bullseye about your favorites below
anyway cut the chitchat let's do this
fortnight has entered the era of scrims
and playing for victories over kills so
we see lots of one by ones and crazy
builds in later circles there's a few
structures you can build which will
either give you the element of surprise
or a slightly unfair advantage the first
is the sniper lookout this one consists
of a spiral staircase and to make the
gap to snipe out of its the top line of
a wall removed not only does this give
you great sight lines it also gives you
head glitching cover check out this shot
lined up on a crouching fall in the
sniper tower from a low angle it isn't
possible to land the shot the staircase
takes the bullet and when it crumbles
and falls you drop down to safety
immediately it's a little annoying to
get the right angle to edit but in
sweaty end games it's a beaut
there's a variation to this build to
minimize your visibility instead of
removing the top three tiles of a wall
try cutting the three squares in the
lower corner giving you this monstrosity
another reliable building one by one
fights is this using a window and edited
pyramid it's possible to snipe out of
the tiny gap it is impossible for all
weapons to shoot through this gap only a
sniper has the ability by the way how do
you know if a sniper likes you
it misses you of course season seven
will likely use permits or portals or
map rotation they're already here in
season six in wailing woods learn where
they all lead to and get the upper hand
against your foes a great way to pick up
easy kills is by hiding traps above
portals they should take down the rift
users but if not remember the sound
effect of them being hit can be heard
from anywhere on the map use it as a
motion sensor allowing you to know your
enemy's position and more importantly
knowing their hurt have we entered the
era of portal combat
and speaking of the bunkers in whaling
woods or in fact anywhere that involves
dropping down in to set up traps at the
bottom you'll be surprised how many
kills you get even the edge of the
corrupted areas during season six was an
easy way to grab a quick kill or two
okay so the turrets it will likely be
vaulted by the time I release this video
or nerfed into oblivion but for now
here's a good way to use it as a roof
tile bear with me I know it sounds
ridiculous the turret has a base
strength of 1,000 HP instantly wood has
the integrity of 140 brick to 80 and
metal for 60 but I'll take time to build
the turret on the other hand is erect in
no time that is a bad choice of words
the tree itself has 400 HP pretty strong
when you're low on mats and want to save
your mettle on controller the turrets
mess up aim assist massively and drags
the cursor away from the enemy in
trouble throw down a few of these and
run around like a headless chicken it's
surprisingly hard to hit them here's the
same scenario without turrets to bullets
took let's move on to bills here's one
from mark nuts at the ramp sniper when
in your tower throw up a ramp on the
side you're attacking edit the ramp or
prepare to disconnect it from your build
the great thing here is that you can see
through the ramp but have invisible
cover in front of needed when the moment
is right confirm the Edit and instantly
shoot your sniper or whatever whether
you prefer the ramp disintegrates and
you look like you actually know how to
fortnight
this is damn good in solos less so in
squads here seems a good point to
highlight the brilliance of two heavy
snipers or a deagle and hunting rifle
whichever you can get your hands on the
deagle and heavy sniper will take down a
basic wall in a single Hicks switch
quickly enough and shoot your second
weapon and once again easy kill
at present the deagle can take down a
wooden wall in a single bullet from 218
meters away ridiculous
that must be punched out soon right ever
been in the scenario where you're
attempting to get into another person to
build but they are using turbo build and
their ping is so high that you just
don't stand a chance well set up a ramp
behind you and jump as you are about to
break the wall the ramp will phase you
through their next wall and now you can
have your own private house hearty how
many times have you been combed in a
build battle well did you know by
placing a simple wall in front of you
you can prevent your foe from dropping
the pyramid over you so simple and
bloody useful to know it's still
possible to be combed but your enemy
needs to perfectly time wood job to do
so a simple wall will keep the majority
of us safe I personally take a deagle or
heavy sniper in to build battles as I
get cold so often one shots and that
wall is down and then I can run away
like the coward I am here's an oaky
method to instantly get into 1x1
structures which is certain to be
removed soon whilst watching courage he
used a rocket launcher sit on top of the
building on the pyramid tile and shot
just over the next triangle piece no
more structure and if they build again
you're already inside noise usually
until to towers you'll find scraps
everywhere some people even choose to
sit in a room and wait for another
player to walk to their death this may
be useful to you if your enemy is
turtled up and has a trap on the ground
you can destroy it safely from outside
not even wasting a bullet after hitting
the tile once with your pickaxe and
closing the door the crit will remain in
the same place and the door will allow
your pickaxe to travel through it I get
that this is a very specific scenario
but hey you never know
speaking of random things like this if
you need a spot to hide in when the rest
of your squad have died and you have
only five health try opening two doors
next to each other and hiding behind
them be careful not to let your axe our
weapon face through the doors and heal
in peace I'll wait for a better moment
to attack come on we all know that this
hiding spot is adorable yeah I added
that to the list just for that joke on
the flip side of that it's possible to
block doors with your belts but the
trick is to do it partially so that you
can still get shots off or better yet
get nades or explosives in the room
before your enemy realizes that door is
out of commission and they no longer
have time to break through a wall a
quick note about editing ramps quickly
and never knew this but thanks to Zack
GG I do now instead of editing stairs
like this to change their direction we
only need to use these two points here
doing so will cut half a second of your
edits and get you back into the action
quicker
so remember edit like this
let's look at balloons do you use them
now me neither but that may change after
this did you know a single balloon will
let you travel faster than running yeah
I was surprised by that one too if
you're stuck in the storm or running
towards the next circle don't ignore a
stack of balloons they could save your
life
now that glider redeploy has been taken
out of solos duo's and squads the
balloons have even more relevance if
you're falling to your death pop a
balloon
well not pop you know you know I mean
which will reduce and even negate all
fall damage depending on the time it was
deployed and how many you used I feel
like we need to put here what kind of
music do balloons hate pop music sorry
balloons can also lift the quad crashes
so you and a friend can float on high
o'er vales and Hills the driver can use
the boost function to navigate the quad
crusher is a perplexing beast which can
actually fly the best way to do this is
to set up a ramp and begin boosting
pointing Sky would keep timing this
right and you can travel across the map
so fast it can't render quick enough
when you get this stuttering effect
lovely oh and don't worry about crashing
at present you don't get hurt this may
change your future so attempt to land on
all fours just in case the quad crusher
doesn't actually need a ramp to do this
you can dive off any mountain or even
use one of the voids to get skyward oh
we haven't looked at the es cups how
much do you hate them yeah I'm not a fun
I think they're here to test out
Mechanics for the winter season but they
do have uses beyond making your enemy
skate around uncontrollably use them to
travel great distances quickly perfect
for escaping the storm the added
momentum is like being a flash a recent
update allows us to heal while sliding
I'm not sure if this is deliberate or a
glitch but for now at least heal and
slide if you're quick enough is possible
to get off a chug-chug it's a little
easier to do a med pack and of course
this perfection or bandages I'm trying
to think of a healing based joke to go
here
it does remind me of the time I worked
at hospital but I got sick of it double
up the frozen blocks on your feet with
the balloons for added momentum it's
like an email Mary Poppins
since the bleed out time was decreased
deciding when to Reza's teammate or to
keep fighting can be a tough choice try
this to get the best of both worlds
first get to your brother from another
mother and protect them with a one by
one inside place down a campfire
once you've finished laying the other
combatants return to get them off their
hands and knees this is an old one but
it works constantly once again when
opening a chest the weapon almost always
drops on the right hand side if you're
ever in a stalemate with a foe remember
that you can even position yourself on
the left of the chest to instantly pick
up the ammo and then face right and grab
the gun very useful for the initial drop
madness in fact if you are ever in one
of those standoff scenarios remember
your pickaxe is a freaking beast and can
kill someone in five swipes in squads
this is damn funny too the ability to
carry additional items has returned if
you've ever been in a scenario where you
want to bring a friend a weapon but you
don't have the space or you need extra
heals whilst avoiding the storm try this
grab the set item look up and right away
keep spamming the item button and juggle
the extra item all the way to your
friend how many times did I say item
then another tip which never gets old
and remains my favorite thing to do in
fortnight the faith free stuff after
building a platform place your favorite
gear a top of it to attract enemies
underneath be sure to place a wall and
trap now edit the floor and confirm the
edit but make sure your head is slightly
protruding this will prevent the
structure from building the thing is it
looks permanent from anyone else's
perspective and this happens so often
I've been doing this for about a year
now but people are becoming more savvy
to it so mix it up use areas where there
has been a build fight and think about
leaving an edited wall to resemble those
of you by others people will let their
guard down and bring their loot straight
to your feet if you're a controller
gamer be sure to check the new updates
added last month we now have the ability
to make our build speed quicker allowing
us to have low sensitivity in fights for
additional accuracy
but crazy build speeds in vertical
battles the update also introduces
custom configurations I'm going to make
a video about all the best ways to
approach it but one I recommend right
now is changing the edit button to one
of the d-pad buttons this will cut out
the waiting time needed to edit and
allows for instant tile modification
check out Zack GG and how quickly he
edits this course
don't tell him he's good by the way
he'll get a big head if you hate Zack as
much as I do put attack sucks and like
always I'm ending with a cop-out but
it's so important to check out the patch
notes buffs and nerfs are implemented so
often you're doing yourself a disservice
not looking but it happens to us all I
forget all the time like recently I
didn't realize that the glider
redeployed had been taken out hmm that
was a fun way to die so there we have it
35 quick ways to stay ahead of your foes
in season 6 and season 7 if you're still
here thank you so much sticking around
to the end it does mean the world to me
that someone watches more than the first
three minutes and alas I will use this
extra time to shamelessly plug my
support to create and Link I'm a
tomorrow if you want to support me that
would be freaking fantastic but no
pressure UVU anyway I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]